when I was in high school came when I
was nine I got molested by a guy with
Down syndrome don't laugh I'm not
laughing why'd you laugh I'm it's just
that it's such a curveball I know can I
just say something I'm gonna say it
again and if you smile okay all right
but his name yeah what's your nib again
chin chin all right give me a second
don't ya give me a second all right I
just wasn't ready for that lioness now
I'm gonna say it again and if and if you
smile I'm gonna leave okay all right
hold on we can't write notes my right
just hold on no cuz then you're gonna
laugh don't laugh don't laugh
get serious B's open it up here when I
was you ready
don't cover your mouth up either hey you
can't cover your mouth
the thing is that I you know I'm telling
you something that's like us it's
vulnerable time expressing truth to you
I do yeah I get serious if you cover
your mouth I just feel like you're
laughing nope let's do it all right so
when I was nine I was brutally molested
by okay you can't say boy because that's
a curveball good dog sister look at your
mouth does that it's not a curse a
brutally had some all right so I had
your tips there so when I was nine years
old every day for a summer in there yeah
all right let's try it again
don't get up I'm sorry how about this
how about I'm not gonna add more
information the information that I have
on the table okay expect that and I'm
not gonna add more all right okay I'm
ready so when I was 9 years old every
day for a summer I was brutally molested
by a guy with Down syndrome I'm gonna
let it slide that was pretty good not
smile that was really good yeah that was
really good and I'll tell you why every
day is because he okay so I lived in
Minnesota people don't know and you did
yeah for eight year that's land of the
long giant yeah I know I used to fitted
I know Minnesota I lived and there was a
you know during the summers there was
like a feel but in the winter it's like
an ice skating rink and there's a Shack
in this field so there's a Zamboni you
know what a Zamboni is right it cleans
the ice yeah right hockey so during the
summer there was like a pretty big Shack
and there was a guy with Down syndrome
that was that lived in there's a man a
grown man I wasn't mad okay and he had
candy on these rafters and he would lure
kids in with the candy Wow and he
wouldn't like you couldn't that suck as
a dick or anything like that but he was
like he would show his penis right and
then like squeeze her out it was like
weird you know but like I didn't give a
[ __ ] about I just wanted a candy we kind
of chanted we target like the one of the
dipping ones dippin dot all of those all
right yeah so every day and this is like
this is connected to my addiction I'm
willing to do anything to get what I
want that's interesting right so even as
a kid it's like I want the candy all
right if this guy's gonna ever this if
this guy's dick it's bad for me because
a guy with Down syndrome penis is
different was it yeah look down I don't
really remember but it was it was just
like it did I don't know man is that why
they call them down sit ideas who want
you to look at my the South don't play
innocent
don't play innocent I was a plan words
I'm for real curious I don't want a soul
there are people who have children who
are down there let's not let's not you
don't know we're not making fun oh we're
now
we're not making fun yeah attention like
that but I'm not a talker it's not a
doctor or a scientist but no it doesn't
go down so you did that for the dippin
dot right I'm not giving dogs how did
you you threw in dippin dipstick we're
all throwing things in here yeah yeah
and so he was like if you want that suck
this he didn't say yes a talk like that
but don't paraphrase it yeah well that's
what happened in the nut ship right so
then check this out so then that
happened and then when I was 12 I
started my parents had my dad is
alcoholic and you guys to have this
refrigerator in the garage and my
mommy's just stalking with liquor and so
I suggest every night we'd go into the
garage and just get 12 even before
school that's how more often started
right and then really yeah so then when
I was 17 this actually happened that was
Eddie I was at a recovery center called
Ocean View Recovery Center it was in
Oceanside California and they have this
thing called knees to knees so it's
basically what you do is you sit in
front of your parent and you touch knees
on two chairs but then all the other
kids is family they're around in a
circle around you it's so embarrassing
I'm embarrassed right my brother was
there I was 14 at time my mom was there
my dad your brother can't wait to make
fun of you what no he does so check this
out so I'm used to these with my dad and
I go yeah when I was nine I was molested
by a guy with Down syndrome and then you
can hear his paws in the room and this
is what my dad did he [ __ ] laugh and
then it made my brother laugh like my
brothers like tears coming down my
brother and then my mom start laughing
and then I start laughing and they think
that we're [ __ ] just crazy yeah but
sometimes you're bright your dad
probably didn't know what to do
he's out of him what he did what you did
earlier yeah well it's right it's such a
curveball it's such a mindfuck
yeah yeah you don't know what to do I
enjoy great works of art no Sistine
Chapel of course beautiful I belong I
know what the Great Wall isn't a piece
of artwork but it is a a man-made
achievement yeah bill turkey that we
goes out yes
I love going to museums and I love
seeing beautiful even albums like a
album like such and peppers wine beetles
yeah yeah and you know over the years I
haven't really seen great art until this
weekend and I bought tickets to see a
movie called choker and I saw an actor
and then we'll we do the best back
acting work out now it just has a new
finish careful baby vision when I walk I
can you okay this is the screen okay
this is the screen right here okay yeah
and when you can act only having this
much of your face in a screen probably
don't you think of this hill in a split
second so this is this is only on the
screen for a split second Bobby to this
way you see right right this way
okay Bobby right way that mile right and
this in the acting in this second I
stood up no in the theatre you didn't
say that no you know what I said I'll be
honest with you I stood up I said loser
I turned it everyone in the field I
don't know Bobby
in fact I told you this earlier when he
was in the bathroom right my
girlfriend's knees from the Philippines
right was in the theater okay
when you we heard your voice yeah on
kalila goes hey did the knees Bobby no
that's just friend you know a Sudanese
[Laughter]
super shitty for you it's a big movie
you're both Beach my mom takes me I went
she goes I'm gonna see the jokesters I'm
excited you know she loves yeah yeah I'm
see excited to see bride like no doubt
mom three hours later she goes oh I
didn't see Brian Hey Dude how dare you
not come on our show
get over here now Bobbie Bobbie Lee just
knocked on our [ __ ] door Bobby is the
best shirts man last night shirt was
fired too bro what's up first of all
don't
don't walk in don't walk in like you're
you walk around like you're on hot coals
you you act all dainty is he gonna be
mean bro and why is your warrior pants a
guy came up to me at the Comedy Store on
camera said you know you're really
important to me
and I never forgot what you said to
Bobby when he was on your podcast and
and you said to him you got to keep
going wow I'm sorry Tunes you put out
the fire for the fuckboys that's comedy
you're doing his Wow
trade or Bobby Bobby's a trader your
trailer Bobby Bobby's Bobby's jeans
Bobby's jeans are $300 Bobby's ratings
bro will do guess bro you came back from
China that's not true I have a very
strong voice yes I do Bobby thanks my
man your podcast appreciate it man have
a good day guys man they crashed our
podcast don't ever open the door again
for those people Bobby Lee looking
button-down there's always one of his
buttons is open like just doesn't give a
[ __ ] he's so funny did you did you roll
out of the couch you cut it down
plays video games yeah these very games
there's a hot girl they have a podcast
he's amazing um moving on he's [ __ ] up
our whole show didn't they great
a lot of dudes up in here the real
business is around just so people know
we're in like an office building
yeah and then me and Brian took this
other first podcast ever being there and
then Thiel followed us here and now it's
bit of a [ __ ] show but the rest of the
offices are like real nine-to-fivers
trying to work it out here that's right
that's right
we don't care though we don't care we
live on the edge only it's like a couple
of Christian boys if you don't believe
in him you go to hell I hope you enjoy a
lake of fire for average is the most
money the most everything I've ever done
is this year good it gets better and
better all right and there are people
bullies like you right these are [ __ ]
comedy but looks like you you I'll just
do it you write Joe Rogan yeah
mark is a little bit like that Marc
Maron a little bit okay to me oh is okay
yeah you you're definitely me again I
know and when I see you dude we throw
tonight when I used to see you back in
the day I used to feel joy why now it's
kind of dread no no a little bit when I
see you like when did I run into the
other day cuz I'm a boy store cuz I'm a
bully yeah it scared they're gonna pull
me into something and you and Rogan and
I I know what you're around that's why
I'm here that is what don't step don't
get nervous friend cuz when I went up
when I shoot up school no you're you're
not on the list no yes
I handle no first guy way only colleague
bro I would shoot you but I'm your fairy
hundred times in just your stupid
[ __ ] face that you guys just saw Joey
no cuz my career that's all you hear
your career your careers on me dude your
career is the reason why I'm here
you just made fun of my [ __ ]
performance I know because I'm kidding
to be a part of like you know you're
kind of a bully to happenes and greens
hate each other well the Japanese
colonized Korea for 50 years and didn't
even let them speak their own like if I
had anything Japanese grew on TV my dad
would go for ku you
they were also the Rimmer I mean one of
the things that it's very hard to talk
about but in World War two a lot of
Koreans were women were forced into
prostitution
to be to service the Japanese Japanese
here Bobby where do you think I grew up
in Seoul
come on man dude you have intensity ooh
I have an accent mmm no just be real I
am man I'm curious yeah I grew up in San
Diego no I figured you grew up in LA not
saying why I had so many prostitutes
before I really got a good real girl
why because I grew up in San Diego and I
couldn't get laid because I was pretty
much unfuckable yeah no I was sure and
San Diego's gotta be joking look at
ching ching laughing - ching ching
but i we used to go in high school like
we used to go to Adelitas which is you
know the biggest brothel in tijuana
I didn't yeah and we used to do these
things called trifectas what we do 3 & a
9 yeah yeah of course
yeah I couldn't go now that's not don't
think that you're talking to the dirtbag
over here I know I factors keep no I
mean these are things that I did in the
past that like I'm not proud of but well
you have to survive mmm and so I white
chicks didn't like me then and then so I
had to get laid and then once I started
doing stand-up at 23 it started flowing
on a regular basis so then I was cool
with it but there's nothing worse for a
young man that when he can't get access
to what I know it's so frustrating this
guy over here to my left doesn't have a
clue as to what that's about you don't
you've always killed it well look at me
right now you've always killed it I
wouldn't say kill his you know varsity
blues you know that that movie yeah
that's his [ __ ] life this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] Colorado softie over here
was the Colorado soft you always got
everything he [ __ ] wanted look at him
you know how I lost my virginity I was
at a party in high school I was on the
wrestling team and I was the lightest
weight and there was a girl
they say [ __ ] everyone you know so the
heavy weights all the way down little
light weights that the [ __ ] announce
last yeah but I waited patiently in the
room
like I remember having my hands in my
pocket and I was just whistling you know
and then I got in there I like I stuck
it it was like a [ __ ] Batcave I bet
yeah and I stuck it in there I didn't
feel anything but I came anyway because
just the idea of horse like that and
then I felt like the weather heats like
you know that man I remember when when
AIDS was we didn't know what what you
know you'd have sex and I would get like
cold in my glands would swell ah yeah
you are probably the worst I've ever
seen my hypochondria I was at F Street
bookstore when I was a in 19mm F Street
bookstore are these uh they're porn
store not porn yeah like adult
bookstores in San Diego yeah and they
have those rooms in the back right where
the floors really sticky yeah so I
remember one night I was waiting tables
and I went to F Street and you could
lock it and you know you can change
tenant channels by these little buttons
and it did a button and it was [ __ ]
calming it oh no like that alright so I
looked at my finger and there was a
little cut there ah dude I had AIDS oh
my god yeah I thought I had full-blown
AIDS
yeah what I did it you know why I've
never met a Korean with each you guys
have you ever met a Korean with AIDS
well there you go
I'm not saying that I can't get it yeah
but I think my body's pretty like yes
yeah yeah yeah he's the guy that sleeps
with the Steve's never started working I
gotta get em on the podcast he's never
stopped working he's amazing anyway he's
married been married a long time what is
he doing with his hands in his pants
right here cause there's no pockets man
no no no he's but so so so check this
out so we're at the improv and his wife
he's been married a long time
these dudes rough-looking guys kind of
good-looking table of guys like maybe
four dudes maybe five guys but they're
they're big they're athletic guys yeah
and one guy just keeps looking back
obviously the kind of guy who's used to
getting female attention and he keeps
looking back at Steve's wife and and
he's but he's giving her the he's being
a little disrespectful he's giving her
the up and down and Steve Steve Ryan
he's wearing an argyle sweater vest -
right and Steve Steve looks at the guy
and he goes and then the guy says
something to his wife oh no like like
Steve goes Steve goes kidding me this
[ __ ] guy something like that oh and
the guy doesn't hear him and I and I
clock all this I gotta go onstage and
then the guy says something like were
you from - the girl - his wife oh and
Steve goes hey bro you [ __ ] stupid or
something she's with me and the guy goes
you had a [ __ ] problem and Steve
stands up and the guy stands up and
Steve again is bigger but he's with
these other dudes and they take notice
they're big and I and Steve is doing
this Steve is literally standing there
like this and he starts going and moving
his tongue back and forth he's gonna be
even back and forth like a Cobra he's
going like this and you can see that it
before guys gonna beat him up but
somebody's gonna lose an eye somebody's
gonna lose and somebody's gonna be
putting a can cut like in a car because
he's just too big he's the kind of guy
that can clearly take a shitload of
punishment you know he's just and he's
crazy enough and he's definitely gonna
fight yeah so he's doing this weird
Cobra thing I and I see disaster and I
gotta go up on stage and these guys are
scary though and I also know that these
guys are athletic and they're not
hearing a peep out of them either and
they're gonna jump so I grabbed the dude
and I go like this I go hey guys guys
guys guys you see who is that the guy
that you're about to fight he is a
homicide detective and he's with the
LAPD and all his buddies are outside at
the bar and they can't wait to arrest
you and they're all as big as he is so
if you guys want to fight a cop a
homicide detective please do so but
please know also you'll be cuffed you'll
be black and blue and you will spend the
next five days in jail I promise you
that's my promise to all of you right
away yeah and they sat the [ __ ] down
they apologized I have a question yeah I
have a question yes but that whole
situation could have been diverted no ow
all right so this is I think oh well
this right here this right here right
you're the guy say something to kalila
were you from this is me yeah hey that's
it oh you would've just said I oh she
would say no I would have oh and you
would have just jumped in and go huh not
me guys no no you can't have me I'm just
saying this girl Lila is not I already
know that Colette is not gonna [ __ ] this
dude yeah this unless he rapes are ripe
another name
kalila okay you met her before let's
ignore I've worked with yeah you've
worked with her before but um anyway
he's not gonna rape her right then and
there or take her out she's gonna hook
up with him so what's gonna happen so I
just go I will just go hi yeah no one's
standing up there's no lies going on
with you saying hi
you sang hi is not really that
interesting to that guy he's a wolf
yeah look uh you know what this is
[ __ ] where you're saying to me right
now this [ __ ] predator [ __ ] alpha
male [ __ ] hey you and Joe Rogan and
all these guys do you I'm a survivor too
okay yeah I'm a gatherer yes I'm gonna
eat the deer me too
no you're not and you're clogged you'll
be waiting with my food and I want your
button here and I'll do that too we
gonna live well we all survive
differently here's how I do it yeah you
said something with that story earlier
when when if I get into a little bit of
trouble I start like if I'm really mad
I'll just I'll take the person on even
if they're as big as Steve yeah because
I might be dead I probably would be but
he'd be blind
[Laughter]
oh yeah yeah not with a blind eye take
them and let's get them off I so believe
Andy yes I know that you're in trouble
yeah got your eyes on I've seen you
drunk and I've seen your energy like you
have a crazy amount of energy like where
you're you're moving at such a pace
where you would be such a handful of
fire horrible
yeah why are you what are you Irish no I
think a little bit yeah
you're you're such a nose adopted
because you talk like you're kind of
like you talk a bit feminine yeah yeah
but you're also like you also have three
kids and you're also you're complicated
you're sevens you're sexually
complicated okay you're sexually
complement your comedic genius and
you're also but you're also kind of a
hunter and a killer yeah oh wow he's
everything the mystical feeling that you
have like childlike yeah that's
something that I [ __ ] then I lost yeah
along the way and you write when you
just said that dude I was just like I
want that back I'm out you know I mean
because now I go to the comedy store I
just pee on the wall yeah I smoke inside
I action side I couldn't agree with you
more
I don't even show up ask him I got my
own spin-off off the Goldbergs and I
love the Goldbergs alone but what I do
is as excited as beautiful as amazing it
as it is in my brain I'm like well to
pilot but you know chances are you know
I'm not gonna I'm not even I don't get
excited I don't know what's gonna happen
my guess is it's not gonna go anywhere
cuz I've been through that so many times
they visited me when I was on animal
practice Rossano visiting rights and I
remember I was shooting something next
door I know you were
well I remember thinking Brian and are
killing it right now right and then like
eight weeks later I'm crying in my car
because it got cancelled I know and it
devastated me of course you know I think
you're good to care about stuff like
that like it's in off see you guys
that's how you deal with it but whenever
you know I'm waiting to hear on to show
someone goes don't think about it's not
important man if it happens happens I'm
like well no I really want to get it
yeah yeah I do think about it and real
quick if I don't get it I'm being really
upset what's wrong I really want song
with the head yeah
not imagine getting it then all of a
sudden you know how much money you're
making a week and then all of a sudden
out of the blue they take it away I was
terrible but I won't practice what I had
inside information I knew that thing was
gonna go away I couldn't tell you dude
what's up no booboo be real I couldn't
tell you no do you [ __ ] swear to God
I swear to God for sure though be pretty
[ __ ] you call yourself a friend bro
but you didn't know for sure that's just
a bad guy thing no it's no it's not a
bad guy cuz what it was was in my mind I
was like I was hoping that I was wrong
right but you know how people talk right
and for me I was like I was like I knew
how bad he wanted and I thought to
myself no no listen I thought to myself
I go I go I I [ __ ] hope that
executive is wrong
I remember good thinking to myself
because I got I wanted to go so badly
for you cuz you and I are in the same
boat you finally got in this show I knew
how badly you wanted it but the guy says
we're having problems and I and I I
would never tell you that why would I
ever tell you I'll tell you why why I'll
tell you why your hope I'll tell you
what it might have gone you know that
you you don't know cuz all of a sudden
the shows a hit and I said something
pretty now I'm and now I'm the [ __ ]
man like a hater yeah you can't do that
yeah you something right now okay you
and I feel like we were friends
ya know really we're friends I've been
to your house so we care about it you
care about each other right and what you
just did there right was [ __ ] sabotage
in the [ __ ] deepest way if you get
rid of audibility fix it with me fix it
with me and the show will go because
then now what I think is is that if you
saw my girlfriend holding hands with
another guy walking down the beach would
tell you that you wouldn't tell me oh no
I tell you that's bad you would tell me
unless he was the guy who listen when I
get in there and you're there and I'm on
set and I hear that the show is having
problems as far as ratings you're right
and how do you say it in how the [ __ ]
right I'm gonna piss on your parade
happiest day your life you're on set
loving it right I'm gonna come in and go
hey by the way that's something broken
did broken did Bethenny
well I was doing inside Schwartz I think
at the time and I wasn't shot at them
yeah well why because it was nested
between Will and Grace and [ __ ]
friends
huh yeah yeah huh it was the it was
right there was like that's it I made it
and Rogan goes low can't hit side the
information he goes that shows going
away you got to know that right
I go huh what what I got up shopping
less I'm redecorated gracing the world
I'm a sitcom I'm I'm famous yeah get the
guy the Will and Grace had gotten
Porsches the year before they had been
their bonus was Porsches everybody got a
horse race we're like and I remember
talking to the director who is the
director of Lola grace we're like you
think we'll get Porsches you Pig wreck
admire shooting ambassadors yeah like do
you think maybe we'll get Porsches and
guess what went away
yeah but Rogen Rogen broken just the
fifth rogue in the true that's not true
talk hey it's going away you know that
show [ __ ] right you know shit's going
away so yeah you gotta know yeah let's
do that
yeah it's on your parade I would never
do that to ya because I don't know when
you see my back ripple and I pull myself
up like a champ like a chimp through 30
times bad while talking to you why
wouldn't I give that to you as it's a
gets a gift it's a gift